UPS of the mortgage giant at Virginia
Tech in Blacksburg Virginia Thursday we
head to George Mason University in
Fairfax Virginia for the fall for the
Book Festival where ya soon a hero chica
will recall his time as a cameraman
during the Vietnam War Saturday will be
in Maplewood New Jersey
Edwards bookstore for historian Amy
night's talk on politically motivated
murder and the Putin regime and on
Saturday and Sunday will be live at the
Southern Festival of Books in Nashville
featuring Ally biographer Jonathan I
history professor Nancy McLain radio
talk show host Erick Erickson and many
other authors that's a look at some of
the events book TV we'll be covering
this week many of these events are open
to the public look for them to air in
the near future on book TV on c-span to
this feels nice hi welcome to sixth and
I I'm Esther for and it's really a
pleasure to be back here on this stage
tonight after a decade a sixth a nice
executive director I'm thrilled to
continue to be involved with this
amazing institution as a member of the
board and that's why I'm here not the
only reason I'm here tonight and I want
to take a minute to introduce you to my
successor Heather Moran where are you
Heather the awesome Heather Moran yeah
so if you have any complaints that's
where they go now and I want to thank
Heather and the fabulous staff for
inviting me to do this introduction
tonight tonight I have a pleasure of
introducing a conversation about an
important new book world without mind
the existential threat of big tech by
none other than our oldest son Frank for
I also want to thank the Atlantic for
partnering with sixth and I on tonight's
program I know there are a lot of people
from here from the Atlantic Jeffrey are
you here
okay the editor the Atlantic there are a
bunch of people here from the Atlantic
and we're grateful that you were
co-sponsors of tonight's program the
Atlantic is a long-standing partner of
6th and I and help us bring journalism
to life through conversations on this
stage
tonight's event by the way is also being
live streamed on Atlantic live Facebook
page
so if you know someone who didn't make
it would have wanted to be here you can
tell them to tune in online I want to
tell you about one more Atlantic event
on September 26th Atlantic's Radio
Atlantic podcast will be here for a live
taping and conversation with one of the
biggest foreign policy challenges of our
time Russia yeah I feel really at home
here tonight tonight I feel like I have
come full circle a bit over 10 years ago
when I became six the NIH's executive
director Frank was one of the first
people I introduced on this stage when
he was in conversation with Tom Friedman
one of the first things we did to build
this institution was to form important
partnerships and it won't surprise you
to know that one of our first partners
was the New Republic of which Frank was
then editor the other thing that
resonates so strongly for me tonight is
how the world has changed in this last
decade it was ten years ago for those of
you who are watching - watching TV and
following this I guess not TV watching
your computers it was 10 years ago
actually this week that Apple launched
the first iPhone it was also in 2007 10
years ago that Facebook and Twitter went
global and when IBM created its
artificial intelligence system Watson
the tech world took the world the tech
boom took the world
storm generating lots of unexpected
consequences and that's going to be the
focus of our conversation here tonight
about Frank's book world without mine so
Frank in addition to being our son was
twice the editor of The New Republic the
author of how soccer explains the world
an unlikely theory of globalization
named one of the top sports books of the
decade he's currently a national
correspondent of the Atlantic and a
fellow at do America Foundation and
another little tidbit it was just
announced this week that one of his
recent New York Times Magazine pieces is
being turned into a film starring
Annette Bening tonight Frank will be in
conversation with Hanna Rosen Hannah is
also one of the most frequent guests on
this stage in her capacity as an author
a journalist a podcast host Hanna's the
author of an amazing book the end of men
and the rise of women and she's the
co-host of NPR's show invisibie Leah
about the invisible forces that shape
human behavior join me in welcoming
Frank and Hannah
I find Gianna so before when we get
going I just want to thank you oops for
making it impossible for me to ever
order anything from Amazon without
feeling incredibly guilty and reporting
an evil monopoly or like liking my mom's
Facebook no you shouldn't we'll get to
them nor should you especially feel
guilty about buying my book on Amazon if
that's what you happen to do so so one
thing I want to get out of the way is
you've talked about this that people
perceive the book as dark which I didn't
perceive it that way at all I mean the
way I perceive this book is it's like
it's kind of like a slap in the face or
like cold water it's the sense that
we've been kind of breathing this air
without thinking about it and then and
then you're just making us aware that
the air like has an ideology and might
have some poison in it right and so it's
like critical that we yeah yeah well
there is I mean there is a dark side I
apocalyptic conclusion one could draw
from my book and so if so my book is
really it's about it's about technology
and technology is been with us forever
it's one of the things that defines us
as human beings but I'm writing about
these inventions that my mother just
described which all happened in the
short span of time and which are all
these totally magical creations but
what's chilling about these creations is
that they're not they're not hammers
they're not they're not microphones
they're not things that amplify humans
these are things that are really merging
with us and their intellectual
technologies that help filter the world
for us and shape our reality and then
they maybe even will become our virtual
realities and so the CEOs of these
companies talked about wanting to to
merge man and machine or let's start
with the merging cuz that's that's the
that's the first interesting idea the
book starts with yeah what is the great
dream of like surpassing human and
elegance and merging with machine can
you just explain where that right dream
comes from right well so there there are
lots of different versions of this dream
but I'll give you the most extreme
version which also happens to be an
incredibly popular version in Silicon
Valley which is the dream of this guy
called Ray Kurzweil who's an incredible
engineer who's now the director of
engineering at Google and he has this
vision which he's called the singularity
which is that we're gonna reach this
point where machines are gonna be able
to create more machines and computer
intelligence is going to be able to
surpass human intelligence and once we
get to that point and he's got a year
picked out where that happens it's like
the last a year but I think it's 2045
and it's the year that it's kind of the
foot gets stepped on the accelerator of
technology and if you thought the last
10 years we're full of change
well after that we're gonna enter this
spectacular space where we're gonna get
uploaded and are uploaded our brains are
actually gonna get uploaded into
computers and we're gonna be able to
live forever and life will be more
blissful than you could even imagine
it's so funny because when you just the
way they dream it it is beautiful but
the way it is depicted in novels yes
it's a disaster you know it's yeah they
and they're not so so so where did you
think there were something beautiful
about it I actually no I mean I really
find I find the idea of living forever
to be a chilling one and with all sorts
of chilling implications for human
morality and for for human life like
what what will make life meaningful if
if we can live forever and ever what
will force us to be human beings if
we're not thinking about the end of days
and so I find that chilling and I also
find the prospect and this gets to the
core argument in my book which is I find
the prospect of merging with machine in
this sort of way to be chilling because
we're never just merging with the
machine you're merging with the machine
that's part of a system right and in
this instance if we talk think about our
merger with face
or Google which is which has happened in
or Apple really I mean that's the I
think the best example of it because
we're now wearing Apple on our wrist and
we're now wearing Google on the bridge
of our noses and we're a step away from
it being implanted within us and you
know Mark Zuckerberg talks about he's
obsessed with telepathy this is this is
this human machine interface this is the
next thing that Silicon Valley is
investing a lot of money in and so what
I find chilling is the idea that I'm
merging with the machine that's operated
that's helping me filter reality and
that reality is being shaped in ways
that I can't even perceive well sorry is
that dark I don't know you know like I
said I read some of the I just read an
apocalyptic novel like that and it was
horrible so yes it is dark but but you
know that's like futuristic I actually
want to talk about what happened yeah so
that's what could happen and what they
dream and so that's the sort of
philosophical foundation that's the
world that they invent it's their utopia
so you learn a lot by knowing what
people's utopia is yeah but but there's
actually I mean a lot of the book deals
with what is and you're just like what
the dream might be one day so so let's
talk about that so banal is that's the
first thing that I think you all need to
start thinking about and why the book is
critical what the word monopoly used to
be a dirty word like right in the course
of history monopoly was bad we would
regulate monopolies we would break up
monopolies so what's what what has
shifted in the culture around the
meaning of that word monopoly what's not
it's not really the call I mean it's the
word monopoly has kind of disappeared
from the culture except for as a board
game right and so it had this incredible
vogue in American politics starting with
the Gilded Age when you're the populist
kind of rise up against the railroads
and then it became this bipartisan
obsession this was this just happened I
was I ran into a friend who's a
conservative today and he was he was
sitting in the coffee shop and as
conservatives do he was reading the
mission statement for national
which is the founding magazine of
American conservatism and he called me
over and he pointed to me and he said
William F Buckley in the founding
manifesto for National Review was
railing against the dangers of
monopolies and so this was a thing that
we all cared about really deeply up
until the last 2530 maybe even longer
years beginning with an article that
that Robert Bork wrote no Law Review
that transformed American jurisprudence
starting with the Reagan administration
antitrust kind of fell out of favor
largely as a vehicle for shaping policy
and so will we talk about monopoly right
now we have a very narrow definition of
it where we were concerned with consumer
prices and so if you look at these
monopolies you'll get Amazon Amazon is
awesome when it comes to price it has
the lowest prices and it will in it and
it'll always have the lowest prices and
in fact it's algorithms help it in
keeping prices low but yet when we look
at Amazon and its size and its scope
there's something problematic about it
or it gives us anxieties and the
question is can we let these companies
grow and grow and grow
yeah haven't we already done that yes
part of the point of the book is that we
kind of let these monopolies yes take
over our lives and we didn't notice
somehow yeah it's right think about them
somehow yeah that that's that's right I
mean in I mean especially you look at
something like the book business so all
our authors are fairly narcissistic and
my awareness of the the issue of
monopolies came when it started to hit
home which was when Amazon got in a
fight with my book publisher my old book
publisher has shed over the contracts
for its ebooks can you talk about your
experience of writing about Amazon and
how they dealt with you yeah well so
Amazon just to kind of refresh
everybody's memory because it was kind
of a esoteric debate but Amazon wanted
to set the price that they sell ebooks
for and that's what they did the first
ebook debuted and Jeff Bezos made it
$9.99 and he did it without checking
with the book publishers he kind of
surprised them
in the course of doing that he basically
deflated the whole book market which is
not a terrible thing for consumers but
it's not great for the book publishers
and it's not great ultimately for the
people who write books and so Amazon was
and why do we mind if Amazon controls
the market for books versus book
publishers I mean just because they used
to control the market for books why do
we care that they don't anymore so in my
view we want a marketplace where there
as many players as possible and you
don't want there to be one dominant firm
because what happens with dominance
ultimately is that you're able to pick
winners and losers because Amma's nobody
is a neutral store there are some things
that always sell better than others and
with Amazon a lot of this is invisible
the ways in which certain products get
certain products they're booked certain
books get pushed over others and you
know just because books are so important
and we want there to be a huge amount of
diversity in what we read and what what
the public has access to and what the
winners are in that market you don't
want one firm having that sort of wall
it's it kind of sucks that you have
publishing as an old gopika industry
there five publishing houses that's not
an ideal situation but what's even less
ideal than that is having one primary
bookstore have control over the entire
market where they're able to set terms
for the way that the market operates and
got it okay if that's the problem then
let's talk about Facebook for a minute
because Facebook is a confusing example
like on the one hand I feel so so
Facebook set an algorithm the algorithm
was supposed to be neutral yeah it
wasn't supposed to favor one thing or
another right but in didn't Facebook
sort of lose control like didn't what
happen with Facebook is that under its
nose this this kind of attempts to
control their universe yeah led to chaos
like led to chaos that they Donald Trump
let's yeah I mean Mark Zuckerberg didn't
want Donald Trump to win the election
probably not no no he was certainly yeah
Donald Trump to win the election so so
what let's just talk about what he
didn't want like fake Russian no you
know fake Idaho Falls sites run by
Russians right when you saw the news
that broke this afternoon where Pro
Publica has a story about how Facebook
was selling it the Facebook algorithm is
neutral and so if you want to go onto
their site and purchase anti-semitic ads
you type in Jew hater and you have the
ability to do that and there's no
policing of them mark why did you pick
that example well know what's wrong with
putting it to that example and so all
right let's just talk about let's just
talk about Facebook in general for a
minute because Facebook on the surface
looks like it's your friends sharing
things and that's what gets put in your
newsfeed but if you just had all the
stuff that your friends were sharing it
would just be this massive information
because your friends share a hell of a
lot and so Facebook created a set of
rules for sorting that information for
making some things rise to the top of
your newsfeed and those those rules are
algorithms there's procedures that they
have for sorting things out and so
Amazon sets a series of rules and so it
decides that when you take a picture of
your family whether that people will
will like that and so they'll make it
higher because what the whole Facebook
system is about needless to say is about
getting you to stay on their site for as
long as possible because that's how they
make money and so there's this feedback
loop that they're trying to create where
they're trying to give you what you want
and so if you're if you're a Jew hater
for instance they're gonna give you a
whole lot of you haters yeah
raise your hands so if you're a Jew
hater they're gonna give you what you
want yeah and that's what happened in
this last election and so it doesn't
that like doesn't that in fact create
more universes you know doesn't create
you less of a monopoly like it could be
like if you're a Jew Vader
but it could be if you're like
transgender and you live in Idaho Falls
like it could be a lot of different
things it's not necessarily or if you
could be if you wanted to you know say
start the Arab Spring and communicate
with other people who wanted to start
the Arab Spring like it's not just the
Jew haters it's just this giant chaos
well so the problem I mean there are a
couple problems with I've been that the
problems are that when it comes to
politics we get lumped not in a million
different constellations we're lumped
into primarily two constellations that
our politics are incredibly polarized so
you have you have to kind of warring
tribes and those two tribes get what
they want and so that information you
get information that confirms their
biases and that drives them further and
further into their corners and in the
end makes them even more susceptible to
fake things because if you're just
seeing things that you want to hear
that's the problem then the other
problem is that in Facebook everything
is about the headline so if you're in
journalism you know that there's a total
art to writing headlines for Facebook
and so you're clicking on headlines
you're looking at headlines you're not
looking at the sources of information so
much and so it all becomes this giant
stew and in that giant stew it's hard
it's hard to know what to trust and what
not to trust and what has authority and
what doesn't have authority and over
time the effect of Facebook and Google
for that matter has been to erode the
distinctions between media companies
which erodes the authority of media and
ultimately erodes truth okay that's the
heart of your book and that's a lot of
different steps so let's talk about them
break it down break it down because I
I'm with you on some and I need you to
convince me on others so the so so that
so we care about the threat to
journalism not just because we're
journalists we care because there's
certain like we believe in a world in
which some institutions have more
authority than other institutions well I
know we believed well you can believe in
way you want to believe in but I believe
in look that in order for citizens to
make good decisions in a democracy
they need good information you can't
make a good choice about who you're
voting for for president let alone all
the other decisions that that were we
have to make in a society if we don't
have quality information okay
so quality information can only come
from a world of gatekeepers like a place
where there are certain people who get
to decide kind of what can cause great
so in order for us to have or in order
for us to have facts that we can trust
they need to be produced in a certain
sort of way operating by a certain set
of rules that that mean that we can we
get that expertise of the reporter or
the opinion maker who's telling us what
to think we need to we need to be able
to believe in them so give me an example
of like where this has gone wrong in
this world so I mean just look at this
last election and all the crazy things
people believed about Hillary Clinton I
mean if you go and you look at the
polling and if the voters specifically
the voters who switched from Obama to
Donald Trump they believed the worst
things that could be said about Hillary
Clinton and that information wasn't
things that they were plucking out of
thin air it was stuff that the Facebook
algorithm singled out for them and and
some of it came through advertising but
a lot of it came just from news so
essentially the idea is like it creates
this echo chamber it's weird because
what it created was a world that was
like more human than human so the
algorithms being it created the
algorithms created a world of like
tribes basically the algorithms brought
back an era of like extreme tribalism
like where you connect it to your tribe
and everybody had their tribe and your
tribes all got echoed and people sort of
filtered into different tribe but I
think the tribalism existed I think what
what happened with Facebook is that it
it's just this erosion of the common
basis for fact and it is what like human
intuition wisdom like we we just came to
confuse world without mind is the idea
without mind means essentially without
common sense or intuition like we just
mistake data for
truth is that is that what we lose so
here's here's what I mean when I mean
world without mind I mean I mean I mean
a couple things one is a world without
privacy and and I think that this is
actually something that we don't totally
understand everybody intellectually kind
of has some dim sense that privacy is a
good thing but why do we truly care
about privacy at the end of the day and
it is not just because we want to do
things outside the public eye for a
democracy there needs to be privacy
because people need to be able to make
independent decisions they need to be
able to think for themselves and if
you're always being watched
then you you're always in you're always
conscious that your decision opinion can
be held against you at any moment in
time and so what you need is a space
outside of a watchful eyes where you can
you can actually think for yourself and
arrive at your own decision without
worrying about your audience so so
that's one thing although people don't
seem to want that like essentially it's
not that people are ducking it's not
we're not on a 1984 situation nice
manipulated situation where people are
being manipulated to you know to
basically like echo their confirmation
bias so people are being manipulated to
believe things that aren't true
necessarily the aversion of privacy is
happening on so many different fronts
right now between Equifax between you
know thing you know kids posting things
about other kids on social media and
leaving a track record through the
possibility that our our reading habits
on Google will someday become public I
mean it's happening on so many different
fronts and I think that it's hard for us
to comprehend really the ultimate danger
of it and when we think about privacy
we just we all say that we want it but
we don't really know why we want it and
we all fear the erosion of it in some
sort of abstract sense but because we
haven't really been slapped across the
face with the consequences of losing
privacy we don't really know what we're
talking about is what
right I mean you slapped yourself across
the face in this book like you must you
know you've slapped many times because
you know all of you right you spent a
long time thinking about it have you
given up anything if I give it like as
this led you to say like I'm not gonna
to like I'm not gonna I'm not gonna it's
it's difficult you know it's it's it's
if you so the book is not apocalyptic
but the book lays out of vision which is
a little disturbing about the way we
live now like it does make you aware
that the way you live now is is a
problem yeah so I wonder if you you know
what it's it's I've tried I've tried on
the margins and but I haven't really
tried to escape myself and so maybe
that's kind of a horrifying testament to
the predicament that we're in that you
can be entirely conscious of all the
pitfalls and still go along with things
I mean I think there are a couple
examples like given the book and and I
think that over time I've tried to I've
tried to find moments where I can put my
phone in a different in a different room
that's it no no I've got a whole arsenal
of things
no but it's that's not it's actually not
trivial I don't think I mean I think to
find moments where you can kind of truly
disconnect from technology I mean that's
kind of that's kind of the to me it's
like the ball game because we're never
going to be able to escape technologies
these companies and these technologies
altogether on our own I mean to me a lot
of the problem is a problem for society
to find some sort of solution for in
terms of applying regulatory solutions
that protect privacy or find a better
way to apply antitrust to just make
these companies a little bit less
overwhelming in our lives and to create
some true competition but when it comes
to what we can do as human beings I
think that the best that we can hope for
and nobody wants to drop out of these
things because the technologies
themselves
are pretty great I mean who wants to who
wants to drop out of Google as a search
engine or as it as it is an email so
it's all incredibly convenient and I
would be I would be I'd be a big
hypocrite if I was saying that that's
what people should do because I used
those services myself but I do think
that you know as I think about my day
and I think about I'm asking you
sincerely I read the book and I thought
okay I understand what's what's
happening I'm just not sure like what to
do like I understand what should be done
in a public policy level about
monopolies but what culturally is like
whenever I find myself in a position of
saying you know bring back the
gatekeepers yeah it just makes you feel
like well but we're talking about the
personal here yeah and so with the
personal there are a couple things one
is that over time I found myself I found
myself kind of first subconsciously
retreating to the paper book and so I
feel like I when the Kindle came came
about I was I was I was with it in an
obsessive sort of way it seemed so
amazing to me but then there was this
moment where I found myself drifting
away from that back to paper and I
started to ask myself what was it about
paper that was beckoning me and it was
it was this whole notion of
disconnecting it's not like the Kindle
was such a terrible device it's actually
it's kind of Placid to read on the
Kindle but we're on screens all day long
all the time every time you're on a
screen I mean maybe not the Kindle
itself but let's say you know you're on
an iPad or iPhone you're distracted
you're connected to a company store
you're being tracked and so you've got
to look for the seams in the system and
the places where you can you can you can
you can disengage so that that's that's
one thing but really the idea so I see
you mocked the idea I'm saying the gary
Stein guard book which is like a little
bit epochal
mean it's the universe you described a
little bit down the road maybe 2074 like
the secret thing that he does is smell
books he goes into his little room it's
magnificent
that's like a rebellious act in the book
they smell so good it smell so good yeah
but do they really I don't know
you should have people when they sign
yeah smell my book smells good yeah
right my book smells like perfume you'll
never want to take it off so so that's
one thing it's the idea of just finding
opportunity for this connection the
second is that I actually think that we
need to be in the end and this is gonna
sound funny but a little bit more
snobbish about about culture and about
what we consume and how we think about
how we interact with ideas in culture
and so the analogy that I have in kind
of extended fashion in the book is to
food and so I love this analogy it was
really helpful so yeah so with food the
food one of the so fifty years ago
TV dinners processed food came and they
seemed so good there were no pots and
pans and you didn't have to go to the
store all the time and it tasted tasted
it tasted pretty great but then I was
efficient it was efficient exactly yeah
and then 50 years later we woke up and
we said holy cow this stuff was filled
with sugar and salt it was it was
engineered to addictive and to make us
fat and it disrupted the whole food
chain and it concentrated power in the
hands of a few of your few corporations
and we have this massive social crisis
because of it with with the childhood
obesity and I kind of feel like the same
thing is happening now with the stuff
that we ingest through through our minds
that it's being reversed engineered to
addictive and it's remade the whole
economy of cultural production and so
because we're addicted to efficiency to
getting things quickly yeah right and to
having things exactly when we want them
and so we're losing some other plane of
ourselves here's the problem with that
metaphor I think it was a great way to
set up the book cause it really helped
me understand the sort of world I was
living in you know we need to be more
snobbish like we've created a very
bifurcated class
system of food you know where it's like
there's expensive elite food and then
there's everybody else's food and so and
so the gatekeeper argument just like
like it smells a little bit like that to
me that like why you know on the one
hand you know people got more accurate
information but on the other hand the
sort of chaos has allowed just like
millions of voices and people who
otherwise wouldn't have had a voice
you know the whole era of blogs when
people could just write what they wanted
like there's also something beautiful in
that yeah there's something horrible in
that chaos but also beautiful in it
I I have some respect for the chaos but
I also think that you need to have just
just as with food we need to have a
healthy healthy ecosystem a healthy
economy of it and so if you just we're
living in a world of so I'm actually an
elitist I'll say that I'll proudly admit
that on this Bheema I'm not and in that
in order to so that to take the food
example so when you have Michelle Obama
telling people how they should eat
that's that's paternalistic an elitist
and you can mock her for doing that but
it also had an incredible well maybe not
an incredible impact but it helped nudge
things in the right direction for the
for the rest of the world and with
culture having so you had so we have two
different models of elitism
there's always elitism there are always
people who are running the system and
you can they can pretend like they're
just responding to mark market forces
and then you get Facebook and you get
people giving people exactly what they
want you get the Wonder breads of
information that that you know that go
down smooth and are cheap and or or you
can have the old the old system of
gatekeeping which had it's had real
problems so the old newspaper editors
were had monopolies in their own towns
and they got too close to power and
there were all sorts of bad things that
you could say and they and they shut out
a lot of people and they should add a
lot of people there was a whole lot of
bad things that they did but they also
had some
consciousness of their power and of
their responsibilities to the people who
read their newspapers and there was an
idea of citizenship at least that was
embedded within that okay so generally
historically things don't go backwards
so we settle it like what like like new
better more diverse slightly more
chaotic gatekeepers is that where we
want to go culturally so I think that
what we want to have happen is we want
to have people take some sort of sense
of ownership and agency over what they
consume and so this is in a way that so
I we want people to to actually care
about what they read just as we want
them to care about what they eat and
that doesn't mean that you pass up that
did you you restrict yourself to like a
small cannon of things that are
acceptable but it means that we just
kind of broadly have a sense that we
need to make more virtuous choices in
that regard okay that's not too elitist
oh that's not it's not just a little a
little but not too much all right I have
one more thing of questions that I want
to have one more question I want to ask
Frank but you guys can can start lining
up but there's a way that will go ahead
what did you want to say I had no but
what's just so galling about Mark
Zuckerberg is that this election happens
you've been waiting all 40 minutes yeah
yeah what's going about Mark Zuckerberg
is that the election happens there's all
this evidence that people were fed junk
fed fake things fake conspiracy and it
happened on his watch and in his system
and it he took no responsibility for it
and so I mean I actually think forcing
those gatekeepers to be more responsible
even if we even if we have to live with
them is it's it's it's filled with peril
because they're so powerful yeah but
isn't that I mean to me that you know
that argument would just sort of accept
and increase the power of Facebook I'm
conflicted about that do I tell marks
are
look it's your fault that Trump was
elected and we live in the world that we
live in you should take responsibility
you should have done a better job
electing Hillary like what that's that's
an inadequate solution I mean we don't
want Mark Zuckerberg to get more
powerful but at the same time their
problems that he has in his system that
he needs to address but that doesn't
solve the problem what solves the
problem is having having him be less
powerful both through consumers and
readers making better choices and also
through antitrust I mean this is the
debate about the white supremacist side
it's like do we want a world where a
server has the power to completely take
someone offline because they disagree
with them this is the debate happening
now or do we not want that under any
circumstances because then they can take
anybody offline yeah well what do you
think I think is question so I think
that I think that you like should storm
whatever it's called storm front like
should they have been ripped off line I
actually don't think that they should
have been kicked off line but I think
that there because that their their ways
in which I think with the the
advertising I think that there's a lot
that they can do better and then with
the people who mean that Rush oh what
wait did you hey during advertising or
with the Russian advertising that seems
like it's you can you can make those
decisions without getting into some of
the stickier First Amendment sorts of
issues and I think that when it comes to
demanding that people that the fake
sites and the spam farms and all those
things that that the Russians used to
exploit the system I think it's possible
to shut those down in a way that we're
just demanding authenticity from the
people who are who are using your system
I mean all the honesty I would want from
Facebook is for them to admit that their
algorithms are not clean their
algorithms are as biased as anything
else and they point toward certain
directions and and for everybody to stop
thinking that algorithms your you know
what else I find calling about Mark
Zuckerberg
we go to question yeah you guys one of
you asked about Apple cuz I never got to
ask Frank like why apples left out of
the book because that seems to me
the biggest change in human existence is
like the vehicle by which we access all
this information that's the closest that
I get to understanding like this is an
extension of my arm the melding of human
and and machine melding of man and
machine to me is most obvious in the
phone and how like how that's got to be
like how fast it's transformed how we
live yeah yeah but you left Apple out
because you really loved your iPhone I
do no I I kind of lumped Apple in more
generally but I was so focused on this
idea of the intellectual technologies
that we're trying to that we were we
were merging with and everything you say
that the iPhones seem I agree with and I
do think that it's the platform that
that for our addiction and it's
obviously designed to be addictive the
the fact that it comes out every year
and and is designed to make the last one
obsolescent there's this idea of magic
that it cultivates that I think is
ultimately at the root of a lot of the
problems that we have as we think about
technology and I also think it's created
created a psychic shift because people
feel like inner panic if they don't have
their phone with them like it is
actually sort of attached to us it is
pretty literally now it is yeah yeah
we're bad yeah okay go ahead hi I thank
you for the conversation so far
I appreciate that commentary on sort of
individual responsibility but I'm not
clear on the policy or legislative stuff
so so never mind even the ideal but like
what are some things that should be
happening that could be happening
because even the behavior changed piece
I mean took a major government campaign
to get everyone to buckle up so I have I
have a couple I'm not I'm not I'm not an
aunt I'm not an antitrust wonk I'm not a
privacy walk I have ideas in the book
that I outlined in a very broad sort of
way that seemed compelling to me what
the Europeans are doing right now seems
hugely compelling to me because there's
really actually a very proud American
tradition of trying to constrain
communication became
that we just don't tolerate monopolies
from extending across our history so
it's at the post the Postal Service was
the first communications monopoly in the
United States and we didn't let the
Postal Service get into the telegraph
business and then when Western Union
took over the Telegraph business we
didn't let them get into the telephone
business and then when AT&T it goes on
and so forth up through the Microsoft
case which was the last moment that we
took we tried to really constrain things
and you could argue the Microsoft case
both ways but I talked to a lot of
people at Google and what they've said
is that if if the if Microsoft didn't
feel hounded by the government it would
have strangled Google in its crib it
would have tried to remake the browser
to try to preserve its monopoly so there
are two things one is I think that we
need to create a data protection agency
in this country there is no law in this
country that governs the use of data
which when you think about it is
astounding secondly I think we need to
think about data in a profoundly
different sort of way because data is
like is it's like the environment
companies do not own the environment and
companies do not own our data the data
belongs to us we can allow them to
exploit our data within reason but when
they handle our data they are that we're
their trustees of that data and because
their trustees of that data we should
hold them to a very high set of
responsibilities for how they manage and
exploit that and then thirdly we just
need to bring back the tradition of
antitrust that doesn't just worry about
mergers although that's extremely
important but when their company is that
we deemed to be too powerful in their
markets
we may get we used to break them up we
did that to AT&T we we seriously
constrained IBM and these were all
important moments in the history of
technology where government action
and helped create innovation and create
spaces for the next new thing so I have
another policy question I'm curious in
lonely in Washington you know there's
been a lot of conversation about back
page and it's prompted a conversation in
Congress around amending the
Communications Decency Act which is the
30-year old piece of legislation that
regulates the internet and whether or
not the Internet should things like
Facebook should be regulated as a
publisher and I'm curious what your
opinion on that is so I'm not totally
well-versed in this issue but Backpage
is a site that the high that you get
where prostitution in its first sex
trafficking happens on that site and
Google basically doesn't accept any
responsibility for that and just as I
mean there it goes to the core problem
which is that these companies view
themselves as neutral platforms and so
we saw this with copyright where when
Google would just and YouTube would post
anything and that even though I needed
it was my intellectual property and they
and it just they just didn't want to
take responsibility for that and so this
goes to the absolute core question of
the platforms and whether if they're not
going to take responsibility for it then
then somebody has to step in in some
some instances and and take
responsibility for them thank you yes
hey Frank and Hana
hi I was a writer it's late and now I'm
the science that are at smithsonian.com
and I have another DC question that's
gonna sound specific but I think
resonates love journalists here so like
I think you're talking about even the
best intention journalists still have to
kind of play by the algorithms that
Facebook sets installed to chase those
numbers so as part of my job I have to
hit a certain traffic and like I'd love
to do stories that we do do about the
transformation of national parks and
about radical efforts to increase
diversity and astronomy but I got a
tooth across my desk the other day
that's like oysters have herpes and it's
killing them
and I have to say yes to it boys have
herpes always sirs get herpes a specific
strain of herpes that's deadly to them
so that's kind of interesting
it goes viral no pun intended right it's
just like designed to be clicked
basically well let me ask you do you
feel like it's changed you're so is it
added to what you do so that you
simultaneously you know look at BuzzFeed
which does like so much clickbait but
also like really excellent investigative
journalism you know like has it added to
the thing that you do or has it just has
it sort of like you know completely
taken off the table things that you
would have not to put you in the spot
does it is it just that like you do the
same work but you put a sexy headline on
it mmm I think it's the first one you
said it's like you strive to make an
ecosystem for yourself or like I
prioritize like features and
investigative pieces but on a daily
basis I have to hit this traffic level
at some point so I have to add in the
traffic drivers and so like naturally
that takes time away there's only so
much time in the day right and and you
might add a sexier headline as anyone
who works for Slate knows right what
that's I mean what what you're
describing is a fundamental tension
which is that when creative industries
could afford to be creative there was
you were able to there was there was
this kind of purity to the pursuit and
that where you were able to pursue the
things that you that interested you you
didn't feel like you were having to
satisfy an audience and I think that
ultimately there is something distorting
about having to satisfy an audience in
that sort of mechanical way and and just
to get to put it more broadly again look
at our politics when I was editing the
New Republic I'm I'm a pretty liberal
guy but the New Republic always had this
ethos of having a very eclectic mix of
of writers and and and was open to
conservatives and open to the center in
a way in which other magazines weren't
but once it became about satisfying the
audience
I felt like I couldn't actually afford
it was like almost a business imperative
not to publish heterodox pieces because
it could somehow hurt you with the
audience and that the in worse than that
there was this it was we were
incentivized to produce pieces that
please the bass and that didn't feel in
the end that doesn't feel very
intellectually honest and it can't be
good for our politics in our culture to
have to do that right do you have any
tips for people in that position
I mean painting sorry
go into painting I said I'm trying to
think of the last creative professions
that are look that are not polluted by
the need to because you're a bit stuck
right like the traffic quota is the
traffic quota which is what your your
superiors are expecting of you on any
yeah well what happened what would
happen if you if you actually just
pursued the the subjects that interested
you in the way that interested you do
you think that they would all sink on
the internet likely yeah no but look my
book is fairly apocalyptic on this score
I mean this is this is where I mean I I
don't think I paint any anything that
really I mean other than searching for
whatever outlets somehow managed to
resist this but the truth is that there
are there hardly any outlets that
managed to resist this kind of price
it's true it's although I feel like my
intern like I don't feel a dearth of
beautiful things to read wonderful
journalism fabulous books I don't feel
that there's there's less of that in the
world I suppose it's just like there's
so much more low-hanging fruit but I'm
not like deprived of beautiful things to
read so maybe it's more about your
internal compass as you said and sort of
keeping in keeping an internal compass
teaching children how to keep an
internal compass making more people have
it because there's lots of like amazing
journalism literature still
out there it hasn't yeah rush right you
know the beautiful soul of creativity
it's just created all this other stuff
at the top of it a little bit sure hi
yeah thank you for both for being here
oh I guess we've touched on it a little
bit but I was curious maybe a little bit
closer to the mic
I was curious to learn or if you could
share a few more comments on like the
sort of marketing advertising structure
it sort of seems like you know you
mentioned that public policy is one
avenue for sort of crea fixing some of
the the sort of poor incentivizing that
happens in the kind of tech industry but
it seems also like without addressing
the sort of economic model of
advertising that there are certain
things that like will still be very hard
to talk I agree with you I completely
agree with you which is why I think that
part of what I'm asking us not just to
be conscious about what we read but also
to to pay for what we read right it just
as I mean that's why the the food model
is actually an optimistic one because
when it comes to food a lot of people in
this country maybe maybe only at an
elite level but have made a decision
that in order to get the good stuff you
have to pay for it and you're gonna
sacrifice efficiency and that you're
gonna you're going to engage in a way
that privilege is a more communal
experience or that makes you feel more
wholesome and so I think that there is a
hopeful example that suggests that
that's possible but ultimately I think
everybody in media that's thinking about
these problems understands exactly that
advertising is a devil's bargain and
that they have to shift much harder in
the direction of subscriptions and
they've made
they've tiptoed in that direction but
they're still not charging very much for
subscriptions relative to what they
charged for for print subscriptions so I
think that that's ultimately gonna
accelerate that was one of my favorite
parts of the book when you went into the
TNR archives and found that some
can't remember who it was it been paid
150 dollars for a piece which is like in
real numbers written or written in the
Great Depression yes more than what on
people get paid to write PS now online
we probably have time for four more so
two on each side
go ahead oh very interesting and I want
to say that your article in August July
and uh the blue Edition thing I think
yeah about your experience is that New
Republic was really amazing thank you
that like debate in journalism so it
seems as if I've heard that the
technology is much like cocaine but kind
of goes in slower and it's not as high
very fast um so I'm wondering do we ever
have a chance
once this started to not be in a world
on all marked up on this technology yeah
so I mean I can I continue to think that
it's possible I mean I would use your
question that we could have made better
just I mean obviously we could have made
better choices along the way as as
within within media and probably as
individuals about how we navigated these
things but I think where we stand now we
still there's still chance you know
opportunities for us to to do better and
in terms of how we how we fit into this
system in terms of what in terms of what
we read the choices that we make how we
spend our leisure time and again it's
just it's it's hokey but when I when I
when I read I mean over the course of a
day like I find I look for spaces I
crave spaces where I can be alone with
ideas and with with words and with with
thoughts and just to think about things
and it's so hard to do when you exist in
this trance where you're sitting in your
clicking all the time and you're worried
about something that you've just posted
to Twitter and how people are going to
respond to it and whether they're gonna
like it or not and that's the classic
example of how the awareness of audience
and the instant response of audience
ends up shaping your behavior as a
writer
and thinker and so book you know just to
be able to escape with a book for a few
for a few minutes over the course of the
day does tend to your soul in a way it
is it is a virtuous choice and to
subscribe I don't people are so uh
Nicole cheated to subscribing to things
now I mean I don't want even I don't
want to embarrass you by asking what you
subscribe to well that's an excellent
choice kudos to you keep it up but but
the Atlantic now has a masthead service
I don't think I see Goldberg in the room
so you won't know that I'm shilling for
the Atlantic but were you there's kind
of an enhanced product that you can get
where you're more of a benefactor to the
institution than just getting the ten
print copies at a cut rate price yes so
you touched on the old versus the new
and my question is when you have you
know establishment journalists like like
the New York Times in the Wall Street
Journal who are engaging on these newer
platforms like Twitter and snapchat and
stuff do you see that as them like
clawing back some ground that they lost
or almost giving in to this new
technology I mean I think it's changing
them in lots of ways I look at not
always for the good I look at a lot of
New York Times reporters who in the New
York Times is what it is the comment
basis or was the common basis for fact
in this country and even conservatives
who used to deride mainstream media
would would actually have to pay
attention to what was published in the
New York Times and so I see a lot of New
York Times reporters kind of going off
in ways that they would never be able to
do in the New York Times on Twitter were
they decry things in very hyperbolic
terms and I think to myself that that's
that's ultimately not great for the
brand of the New York Times but even
worse ultimately not great for the
project of constructing a common basis
for fact yes
hi thanks for writing this I think
you've delve into some really important
questions you mentioned earlier that we
all kind of think privacy is important
in some vague way but haven't
necessarily cashed out what that means
fully and you alluded to one possibility
which is that it allows political
dissent when there is private discussion
among people but it seems like privacy
has sort of different senses right
there's the privacy of your thoughts
within your own mind yes this is within
groups of people and so I'm wondering in
the first sense if there's something
more you can add about maybe what's
being lost in that kind of individual
private realm when we don't have privacy
and maybe I mean is anyone really saying
at this point that technology is
interfering with our ability to have a
private thought per se other than
through just distraction and and is
there more you can add about maybe
what's being lost there well it's it's
not just distraction but I think it's
also you're you are being tracked there
is a material record being kept of the
things that you read and the things that
you search for and all that is is a
portrait of your mind I mean Google
boast I mean it was so one of the things
that is kind of she was chilling about
this project was that you could go back
and you could I've read everything that
the tech executives wrote about and said
about human nature and Eric Schmidt
boasted that Google knows where you're
gonna be tomorrow with in it with the 24
hours within like you know 500 feet
based on your past patterns and that
Google Google could predict your
behavior based on path patterns and so
what it supplies you with information
it's really just supplying you with
information based on this intimate
portrait that they have of your your
psyche and does that end up having a
chilling effect on you now probably not
so much because we all collectively
choose to ignore the fact that we're
being tracked but I think that over time
it's going to start to exact a toll
I just wanted to I think we probably
have to wrap up but I wanted to say one
other thing about about this book in
this project which is that as you can
tell a lot of these questions are
extremely hard questions where there
isn't an obvious solution that that's at
hand to us but we we all have this
nagging sense I think that something's
going on that things are changing and we
hope that it'll change that change in a
fantastic sort of way and then you wake
up on November what it was fifth or
sixth and you realize that the world
isn't necessarily marching in towards
progress that were not necessarily
moving in a utopian sort of